[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les mathématiques de la relativité
générale partie 7
l'équation d'einstein votre modèle
mathématique est terminée d'une part on
sait décrire une géométrie
d'espace-temps et notamment sa courbure
et en déduire la façon dont se déplacent
les objets grâce à l'équation des
géodésique on a pour cela développé tout
un tas d'outils mathématiques comme le
temps soeur métriques les symboles de
christophe elle ou encore les temps
soeur de courbure de richie et la
courbure scalaires d'autre part on s'est
également décrire le contenu énergétique
de l'univers est ainsi les objets et les
astres qu'il contient à l'aide d'un seul
outil le temps soeur énergie impulsion
l'idée la plus puissante en relativité
générale va être de relier ces deux
notions à l'aide d'une seule équation
on va écrire une égalité entre d'une
part la courbure et d'autre part le
contenu de l'univers
cette équation qui se présente comme une
égalité entre la géométrie et le contenu
de l'univers est ce qu'on appelle
l'équation d'einstein
dans notre modèle mathématique
l'équation d'einstein est l'unique
équation qui ne se démontre pas c'est
une équation que l'on admet car il
semble parfaitement correspondre au
monde qui nous entoure cette équation
renferme toute la qualité prédictive de
la relativité générale
elle permet de relier directement le
modèle mathématique abstrait à la
réalité concrète des astres dans
l'univers habituellement l'équation
d'einstein prend la forme suivante sous
cette forme tous les termes à gauche de
l'équation représente la géométrie de
l'espace temps on y trouve le temps
soeur de richie la courbure scalaires et
le temps soeur métriques
le terme à droite de l'équation
correspond quant à lui au contenu de
l'univers
il s'agit simplement du tenseur énergie
impulsion que l'on multiplie par une
certaine constante qui détermine
l'intensité de la gravitation dans
l'univers
cette constante dépend de la vitesse de
la lumière et de la constante de
gravitation de newton
elle est ici pour s'assurer que la
relativité générale donne bien les mêmes
prédiction que newton dans des cas de
faible gravité
il est très important de comprendre que
l'équation d'einstein est extrêmement
complexe à résoudre
en effet comme on l'a vu précédemment le
temps soeur de richie et la courbure
scalaires qui interviennent d'à gauche
de l'équation renferme des calculs
complexes de dérivés de somme et de
produits du tenseur métriques de plus
les deux côtés de l'équation sont
intimement liées le contenu de l'univers
va influencer la courbure de l'espace
temps mais réciproquement la courbure de
l'espace-temps va à son tour influencer
le mouvement et l'évolution des astres
résoudre un problème aussi intrigué est
pratiquement impossible dans la plupart
des cas il est donc nécessaire de faire
des approximations numérique et des
simulations informatiques pour résoudre
de tels problèmes
[Musique]
dans l'équation d'einstein la courbure
de l'espace-temps est incarné par le
danseur de richie et la courbure
scalaires qui en est la contraction mais
dans un espace temps comme le nôtre à
quatre dimensions l'équation d'einstein
possède une symétrie très intéressante
l'équation reste vrai s'ils ont
interchangé le temps soeur énergie
impulsion avec le temps soeur de richie
et que l'on inverse la constante
d'einstein
cette nouvelle expression est
complètement équivalente et on verra par
la suite qu'elle peut être plus simple à
utiliser
l'équation d'einstein est très complexe
mais elle accepte quand même un certain
nombre de solutions exact la solution la
plus simple et la plus utile est la
suivante
imaginons un univers vide dans lequel on
place un astre massif de masse grands
thèmes
on suppose que cet astre s ferrique
statique c'est à dire qu'ils n'évoluent
pas au cours du temps et qu'il ne
possède aucune charge électrique ou
propriétés magnétiques cet astre peut
représenter une étoile comme le soleil
ou bien une planètes comme la terre
notre objectif est de calculer le temps
soeur métriques et donc la géométrie de
l'espace temps en 1 point à l'extérieur
de l'astre tout d'abord choisissons un
système de coordonnées
on choisira d'observer le point depuis
une très grande distance et de mesurer
le temps sur notre horloge t la distance
entre le point et le centre du repaire
airs et deux angles et à efi
notre point se situe dans le vide
par conséquent le danseur énergie
impulsion yens nul grâce à la deuxième
version de l'équation d'einstein
on en déduit que le danseur de richie
doit également être nulle pour
déterminer la métrique à partir du
tenseur de richie les calculs sont
fastidieux et nécessite de résoudre de
multiples équations différentielles mais
grâce aux différentes symétrie et
invariance du problème il est quand même
possible d'obtenir son expression exact
on l'appelle la métrique de
schwarzschild la métrique de
schwarzschild dépend de la masse de
l'astre en particulier si la masse vos
héros on retrouve la métrique de
minkowski qui décrit un espace temps
vide mais autour d'un astre comme la
terre la métrique de schwarzschild nous
indique que l'espace temps se courbe
plus on se rapproche de la planète plus
la courbure devient importante dans le
cas d'une planète sa surface va nous
stopper et en son intérieur
la métrique de schwarzschild n'est plus
valide mais dans le cas d'un astre
suffisamment compacts dont la surface
est très proche du centre on va pouvoir
se rapprocher suffisamment pour
atteindre une distance à laquelle le
terme temporelle de la métrique vos 0 on
a atteint un point de non retour
le temps est dilatée à l'infini c'est le
rayon de schwarzschild l'horizon d'un
trou noir
[Musique]